die afg hat verluste eingefahren den nrw
genauso wie bei den acht landtagswahlen
vorher auch und auch bei der
bundestagswahl die ganze zeit über war
kinopalast parteichef nun regt sich
vorsichtig formuliert unmut in der
partei der will sich den schuh aber
nicht anziehen bis jetzt wollten vor
vier monaten die partei verlassen habe
seid ihr ja schließlich auch parteichef
gewesen sagt kruppa und außerdem
erinnere ihn diese debatte mit der
kritik von immer denselben ans kempten
dasein ist diejenigen gewesen die sich
über ein nasses zelt beschwert hätten
die auch selber ich zitiere ins zelt
hinein gepinkelt hätten jedenfalls will
er wieder antreten in gut drei wochen
beim parteitag und da könnte es dann auf
einen showdown hinauslaufen denn auch
pia
rechtsaußen vom verfassungsschutz
eingestuft als rechtsextremist und
beobachtet bekundet auch interesse also
unruhe ärger rechtsruck alles wie immer
bei der alte